hey you wanted to see me i did think
fast oh my god
hey dr buttons i mean
my old calculator it doesn't have a name
why did you throw this in
i just got off the phone with our old
boss from indianapolis and apparently
there may be some sort of a budget
problem in eagleton
he asked if maybe you and i wouldn't
have a
look you in butch county and the some
dance kid together again
hmm auditing bros
this enough gang we have intel on a drop
house
used by alexi bisco a captain in the
ukrainian mafia
oh he should be psyched that's a very
up-and-coming mafia
his soldiers use the site to drop off
money and pick up weapons we need a
couple of teams to do long-term
stakeouts
i'm out four hours is the most i've ever
spent alone with any human it was the
worst experience of my life what about
that time we drove out to boston
together that was about four hours
oh i see what just happened the only
decent advantage is this
condemned hotel across the street we can
go in as exterminators but too much
movement will look suspicious
it's an eight-day op so two teams will
do four days each boyle and i are in
okay that's one team who wants to
relieve them if extraction is a risk the
two of us can do the full eight days
a hanukkah miracle no that is too long
to be holed up together like that
i did a six day stakeout once did not go
well
that's not gonna be a problem for us the
only time i ever yelled at charles was
cheering him on at his roller boogie
competition
we never fight it won't be a stakeout
it'll be a steak occasion
stake me out tonight i don't want to let
you
go till we catch this guy we already
have a theme song
that concludes this meeting
store next to them as release so what
means they're not expanding maybe you're
shrinking no
that could be shrinking no because the
sign is centered perfectly above their
store no sign of the sign being moved
it's lunchtime with no sign of anyone
coming in
or out which means they're not taking
new customers out to lunch
which means they're not acquiring new
business so once again you know growth
well there are clouds clouds in the sky
i mean it's going to rain bad for
business well what if they were all too
cumulus and not zero stratus
why are you okay michael whatever your
clouds right
shut up okay so
you're going now i'm gonna go in in
exactly ten minutes we have never met
each other we are complete
strangers right also we're gonna need a
signal to bolt out of there in case
there is danger
and that signal is lick your lips try it
no no no like this
good ready to do this yeah all right
here come the sharks
[Music]
okay let's take a look at this list of
assets owned by the eagleton government
400 segway scooters sell em they're gone
you had six full-time baristas on the
payroll the baristas are gone
as are the masseurs and the full-time
barista who provided coffee
for the masseurs it is excellent having
the old band back together again
you know what this calls for some
celebratory lunges
one two
falcon one do we have a go the light is
green tiger one what are you gonna say
when he crashed through the window hey
there
sorry for dropping in goosebumps jake
goosebumps
this equipment secure check weapon
loaded check did you have breakfast what
that's not on the checklist
i added it because i care about you no i
did not have breakfast unacceptable look
in your pocket
hey there's little chocolate chips in
this yeah i'm not an idiot i know how to
trick my best friend into eating his
fiber
all right bar digested mission go
hey there sorry for dropping in
was it cool it felt really cool yeah
yeah it's pretty cool pretty cool
well we're wrong hi you have fudge on
cheek
oh from the breakfast bar boyle
anything nothing
what if this doesn't work what if the
office
actually goes under
then it was an honor to have worked with
you
all right favorite moments
in dunder mifflin history go
my first day when you hazed me
by spraying me with a fire extinguisher
that was hilarious
[Laughter]
my first sale my promotion to assistant
regional manager
our basketball game
when you took me to the hospital and
told me that you cared about me
all right okay that's enough that's good
what were your favorite moments oh
all of them i loved them all
every single one
what about when jan said the branch was
closing god
what are we still doing here it's over
let's go home get the car
oh this is such a stupid idea
this was so stupid
i'm such a stupid idiot i let everybody
down
everybody hates me i lost everybody's
jobs
nobody likes me anymore oh my god what
stanford is closed michael where did i
close
stanford is closed separately we did it
we did it
we did it
oh man
how did we do it i don't have no idea i
don't understand
hey ron you want me to read you what i
have so far in my welcome letter
nothing because you and your jerk
predecessors didn't give me anything to
work with
did you print this out i heard the
printer going
yes you could have just handed me a
blank piece of paper
oh wisdom finally thank you so much
you can also keep the photo thanks for
the memories
good god i don't remember this that
that's the wrong one
but the real one's very bad as well i
want you to know that i'm replacing the
welcome letter with this ad for yearning
by dennis feinstein
so goodbye distilled wisdom of 50 years
of experience hello disgusting
fragrance flap let me buy you dinner no
i insist you buy me dinner the usual
marta me too murder you got it oh ron
i really made love to the pooch on this
one screwed the pooch i don't like that
term so vulgar
run not suck today i'm sorry there's no
other way to say it
they're a bunch of career bureaucrats
what did you think they were gonna say
to you
leslie you are the next link in a
wonderful chain that stretches back to
when our town was founded and we believe
in you and we support you and we'll be
following your career
you are the chosen one or something
well okay so that was the problem no you
know what the worst part is
is i want to be parks director but every
single person who was parks director
hated their job and hated everyone they
worked with
are we gonna hate each other someday i
don't think so hmm
i think we're gonna be fine
anyway the point's moot because you're a
park director now and you're not going
anywhere and i'm not making you go
anywhere
i'm not gonna stab me in the back or
anything so maybe i should go somewhere
maybe i should move
to eagleton oh god the thought of that
leslie you don't have to move to
eagleton when i become city manager
my job is yours of course my first
active city manager will be to propose
eliminating the parks department
although i expect a spirited debate with
leslie
who knows what the future holds for me
maybe i'll
leapfrog ron's job and become city
manager
of course my first act as city manager
would be to double the size of the parks
department
although i do expect a fight from ron
but i'll win
thank you darla why would anybody ever
eat anything besides breakfast food
people are idiots leslie
you